welcome to episode 25 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with andrew
doyle andrew doyle is a british comedian
playwright journalist and political
satirist
aka the man behind titania mcgrath
if you do not know who titania mcgrath
is please go on twitter and search her
she's the most painful most accurate
portrayal of over-the-top sjws that you
can find
she to reiterate she is a satirical
character
made by andrew doyle has almost 600 000
followers on twitter
and is the author of the book woke a
guide to social justice
her most recent book which is now for
sale is called
my first little book of intersectional
activism
highly recommend it this podcast was
obviously recorded in advance i'm still
in serbia in it and i am not currently
i am in toronto this episode is a bit
more political in nature but we do delve
into some interesting topics like what
the hell does intersectional activism
even mean
how did andrew doyle learn how to speak
like an sjw
where does that language originate from
i hope you enjoy it
i learned a lot i think it's an
important episode given what's going on
now politically
a word from the sponsor of this episode
i've been using true local
for a couple years and they are my go-to
source for meat at home in canada
what they do is they partner with local
farmers and butchers in your area
to source some of the best meat things
like a hundred percent grass-fed and
grass-finished beef
pasture-raised or rwa chicken means
raised without antibiotics
lamb buffalo and over 100 different cuts
of meat that you can't find at your
grocery store
generally you build your own
personalized box that will give you
enough meat for the month with only the
products you want
and it shows up at your door another
thing i've been loving with it
is all the products come individually
portioned and vacuum sealed
if you've been thinking about giving
true local a shot i'd say it's worth it
use the code mp to get two free ribeyes
with your order
this is where i get all of my meat for
us canadians
enjoy the episode
[Music]
andrew doyle welcome to my podcast
thanks for having me
so i start the podcast off by having the
guest give a bit of an intro
so would you do that um i invited you on
obviously because of the creation of
titania mcgrath but
yeah i'll let you go ahead yeah why not
i mean i'm always terrible at describing
myself and what i do i make it sound
really boring so i'll try and i'll try
and liven it up well
i suppose i'm a writer a comedian my
background's in stand-up comedy but also
playwriting and
writing for the radio and the stage and
writing musical theater as well
and the titanic mcgrath character is
relatively recent i
i just started that a couple of years
ago and that's that's a deliberately
explicitly satirical take on uh
what i'd call the social justice
ideology or the social justice movement
um and i set her up uh
through twitter the idea there being
that of course a lot of social justice
activists
twitter is their their preferred field
of battle isn't it that's where they
operate that's that's how they
disseminate their ideas
so i thought the obvious way to satirize
them is through twitter itself and i so
i set it up there
partly uh because everything was
annoying me so much you know all of the
craziness that was going on
but in addition to that i was also
entertaining myself you know and so i
wasn't out about it i didn't tell anyone
it was me
so i didn't even tell my friends no one
knew it was me there was a real
liberation to that you know i could just
completely inhabit
this character and then i got outed by
the press in the uk
uh and so that was that so now what
it hasn't changed anything in so far as
i carry on tweeting us to tania in the
way that i always did
the main thing that's changed is that uh
now everyone knows it's me so whenever
she says something that offends people
i'm the one who gets the flack for it
whereas before they were just railing
against a figment of my imagination
which was a bit more comfortable so
so that's the that's my basic background
i've sort of done less and less stand up
now now that i'm more into writing
although i did do a stand-up tour
last year last january of course there's
no stand-up now anyway because of
coronavirus so
in a sense uh that's okay by me um
that i've sort of backed off on that a
little bit and i'm just focusing more on
the writing and um yeah so that's what i
do
so i found out that was that was good
that was perfect that was perfect
i'll spice it up more in the intro yeah
yeah
great uh i found out about you because
of titania mcgrath
how did okay how long were you did you
manage to keep
your identity hidden so that would have
been about
a year about a year so so i started it
in april two years ago so that's what
april 2018
and i kept it going and what happened
was about six months in
i got it started getting bigger and
bigger and i didn't expect it to and and
something had happened whereby i think
because so few comedians and and writers
were mocking this stuff and i i think
people just gravitated towards it
because they were they were sort of
relieved that there was this thing going
on
and there were some market i'm not
saying that no one was but not many you
know there was a kind of paucity of
of attention towards this target um
and i know why i think it's because the
the entertainment industry has become so
overrun with this social justice idea
that's
so in order to get anywhere in order to
get on tv you're probably shooting
yourself in the in your in the foot if
you're going to mock it i mean
luckily for me i you know i i i don't
really care
about that um i think i've you know i've
never been particularly fashionable so i
was never going to get on tv so i
thought fine
doesn't matter i'll just i'll just go
for it and um so about about six months
in i got a call from my
agent who's my literary i've got two-way
you've got a comedy agent a literary
agent but it was my literary agent
saying
he's been in touch with a publisher and
they want to do a book that sort of
talks about the woke culture and
satirizes it do i know anyone
who ever does this and i said well i do
i've got this character
called to tiny mcgrath and he was
following her and he didn't know it was
me
so this was a complete kind of accident
and then he said okay well great write a
picture a book and i wrote the pitch
and i got the deal so by the time then
the book came out in march
2019 so about a year after i'd
invented the character and um
what happened was i was outed there was
a an article in
the the times newspaper or the sunday
times maybe
um uh by a journalist called rosamund
rosamond irwin i believe uh i hope i
haven't got a name wrong uh ross
mcderwin who
who had basically investigated who it
could be and she'd whittled it down to
two people
uh which was me and another satirist
called lisa graves who's a friend of
mine
and she thought it was one of us and
she'd done an incredible job sort of
reading all my articles and things and
she'd read an advanced copy of the book
and she'd worked out some of some of the
quotations were similar
and things like that it's amazing she
even phoned up a friend of mine saying
do you know if andrew is doing this and
i mean proper old-school investigative
journalism so that's what happened there
and then um a comedy website called
chortle in the uk found the smoking gun
it was some kind of
turtle yeah it's sorry it's just
it's a british word it's a quaint
british word for laughter
it's just not something that anything
american would be called that's funny no
no exactly um
but they found some sort of document i
think it was uh
it was a book fair in somewhere in
europe where
um the publisher that had published
accidentally put my name
next to the book as it was announcing
the book so that sort of
sealed it for me yeah so what actually
happened is i was outed
the week of the publication of the book
in the uk
and that was not an accident what
happened was it became a story then
and i was on invited onto tv and onto
radio to talk about it
and it became quite widely reported so
it really elevated
the book because the story was suddenly
that you know this ex-teacher stand-up
comedian
has created this character so it looked
deliberate it looked like i completely
engineered
this whole publicity thing but i'm not
that clever it's not that it's it's that
it i was just outed uh
coincidentally at the same time and
that's sort of how it happened
okay what does woke mean
well woke used to mean uh if you go back
to the uh
the various black civil rights movements
of the 20th century it meant
this being alert to social injustice and
particularly when it comes to the issue
of racism so it was
it was then later co-opted um i mean it
was used by various people i know
there's a
i think there's an erica badou song
where she she uses the word from the 90s
and
so the word had this basically good
meaning this sort of
this this thing about tackling racial
injustice which which i would be all for
and if all that woke meant
is to be alert to racial injustice and
to not
approve of it then i would call myself
woke that would be great
that's not what it means anymore the
word kind of got hijacked in around 2012
2013
by a particularly aggressive intolerant
illiberal social justice movement
that applied it across the board it
wasn't just about race anymore it was
about all identities because this is a
this is a movement that is underpinned
by identity politics so it was about
race gender sexuality uh trans issues um
body positivity all these kind of things
and they started using the word very
liberally very promiscuously
um and then what happened you get
another development which is um
people like me were using it to mock the
people who were using it
and you also had then uh some
conservatives and some uh
very sort of uh vehement conservatives
using it as a term of abuse against the
social justice movement so then
then and that was roughly around 2017
and then the people who used to
self-identify as woke suddenly started
saying
woke isn't a thing it's just a word for
conservatives to attack us that's all it
is
and they protect pretending they never
used it well
i've got hundreds and thousands of
examples of them using it so they can't
they can't unfortunately for them
there's a thing called the internet and
we can see
that it used to be a very common word um
so now
it's got really really complicated um
and to an extent that i'm using it less
and less because i don't want people to
think
that i'm just using it as a lazy slur i
use the word woke
because the social justice ideologues
used to use it for themselves and i'm
just using the word that they used and
some of them still do
i know portland state university
recently had a woke week
uh or one of the departments had a woke
week um so people are still using it
in that way and that you know that's
that's fine uh i don't have a problem
with that
um but i use that word because it's a
it's a it's quite a decent shorthand
isn't it because how else do you
describe
this phenomena you can call it the the
social justice movement well that
that doesn't really work because social
justice sounds like such a wonderful
thing
and of course the people in the movement
aren't really for social justice or
they're certainly not achieving it
so there's that you could call it
identity politics or the identitarian
left but that's a bit cumbersome and a
lot of people don't know what
identitarian means
you can call it critical social justice
which is what james lindsay
calls it um because that's one of the
phrases that robin d'angelo has used to
describe the movement
oh my god so no one knows what to call
call it
and woke is quite a handy shorthand for
it i get i guess
is that sort of answering that was a bit
much you i don't know no no no no that's
exactly what i want
i've got some i think i have some other
terms to throw at you because i
like i know i know of this of course
because of social media but i
i i didn't realize woke was that old of
a word
it's an old word it goes right pretty
far back yeah yeah
yeah that doesn't really surprise me
though the intention was good
uh when it was initially used and and
you'll often find people saying
that when i talk about why i'm anti-woke
they'll do that thing and they'll say
but if all woke means is to be alert to
social injustice why would you be auntie
that
and like because and i'm like because it
doesn't mean that anymore
it really doesn't you know it's it's it
implies this whole other
movement that just that has as you know
uh emerged from this from a kind of
perverted version of post-modernist
theory
uh it believes that language is the the
uh controls everything even it shapes
our reality
uh not that language isn't important but
they believe that there is nothing there
is no truth beyond
language you know they believe that
there are these nebulous invisible power
structures that dominate society which
is straight out of
the work of michel foucault um but only
they are trained to see it you have to
have a degree in
critical race theory or gender studies
or queer theory to be able to detect it
and those are the elite they're the sort
of people who have this kind of magical
power to detect it and you just have to
accept it when they say
there is institutional racism or
systemic racism or whatever
you have to say okay people just go
along with it because they're
intimidated by the jargon they don't
know quite what it means and um
but actually it's based on a fraud it's
it's it's ba it's built on sound
and therefore uh it's it's imperative
that people understand
where it comes from and and they're able
to penetrate the jargon that these
people use and get beyond it
because the jargon in of itself is a
trick it's a it's a kind of highfalutin
language
that means that people won't engage with
them there's a very good reason
why the vatican for many years didn't
want the bible translated into the
vernacular
because it meant that only the high
priests could uh could
interrogate the the ideas that are
within the book so
you know this is why people were burnt
at the stake for
translations uh and it's the same thing
with the with
the woke they they want this esoteric
language which keeps people at a
distance
and it enables them to control them and
i see it all the time i see all the time
on social media when someone
tries to say oh but hold on a minute i
don't really believe in this idea of
white privilege or or whiteness or
anything like this and then these
academics will come back at them
with all this jargon they'll intimidate
them they'll say you don't know what
you're talking about i've got my degree
but what the other people don't know is
those degrees are phony those degrees
are fraudulent and
and there's really nothing to it it's
just people who are uh
they're throwing out slogans as a
substitute for thought they're throwing
out
uh terms uh because terms that are so
they are obfuscating terms that that
sort of redirect you from
from the fact that there is very much
there's there's a kind of vacuum at the
heart of the ideology there
um so that's that's sort of i can't
remember your original question but yet
again i've gone off on one
you have to stop me mikayla if i do this
because i you know
i like it i like it okay i will i will
stop you though
what is somebody who isn't educated in
that type of manner supposed to do in
response if
because you can't some of these people
you can't communicate even the person
you you portray online to tania mcgrath
i don't know how you learned to speak
like those kind of people speak okay
let's let's have that for a question
how did you learn all of this language
because when i was uh at university and
i i did
i did three degrees i ended up doing a
doctorate in um
early modern literature and a lot
at the time uh queer theory and
foucauldian theory
and and post-structuralism generally was
at the heart of english literature
throughout the uk
it was you couldn't really uh engage
with literature
unless it was through this lens or at
least acknowledging
this lens and and so therefore i'd read
it all i'd read all
particularly the stuff that pertains to
literature and and it was completely
dominating the humanities so and i used
to go to
queer theory conferences i mean my
thesis was
around the the issues of sex and gender
and sexuality so
inevitably i was i was involved in this
stuff and i'd go to these conferences
and it would all be about foucault and
it would all be about derida and lyotard
and all these
uh these french post post-modernists
from the 1960s
and so therefore i just knew the lingo
and i also cynically
knew how to deploy the lingo in order to
do well i remember as an undergraduate i
knew that if i used certain words i'd
get good marks
i just you know did that yeah it's it's
like a trick
you throw down the word discourse or
phylogeocentrism yeah
and you don't really need to know what
it means like it's
there's something weird at the heart of
the humanities it was happening even
then
like my supervisor at the time said to
me you know the reason why these people
use all this jargon is because the
publishers don't understand it
and they'll just pass it through and all
of this stuff gets published because
because again everyone's too scared to
say oh i don't understand what that
means
well maybe you don't understand what it
means because it's really bad writing
because writing should be clear and i
don't care how smart you are
i don't care how how much of this theory
you've learned if you can't convey your
ideas with clarity you're not a good
writer
don't get who you are okay
okay how i know that's how i learned for
the job yeah well i can remember my dad
probably in 2010 i'm not sure when he
but he bought a bunch of
books and i can remember him reading
darada and foucault and just
swearing upstairs that's a reasonable
response
that's a reasonable response apparently
derek i mean i've read derek but
not in the original french and
apparently that means that i i will
never have a full understanding of it
isn't that how the quran works
that's a very good isn't it though it
actually is there are translations of
the quran but they say that
the only you have to read it in the
original language to get the sense of
and actually there's something to that
isn't there you know i mean
whenever something's translated it does
lose some some of its original
essence um but the added problem with
daredevil is he was deliberately trying
to play with language and he was
deliberately
um be actually being incoherent to make
the the point so that doesn't really
help foucault is easier to read
um and again i've only read him in
translation but um
but yeah so uh anyway uh
all this stuff i think i get what you're
saying is that what should people do you
know what
it seems quite intimidating it's not fun
like it's not fun to read that stuff
so what i'd suggest is i wouldn't say to
people go and read the
the french post modernist because i
think you drive yourself insane
i think a good a good way to do it is
read about them read um
james lindsey and helen pluck rose's new
book cynical theories which is a book
that
basically outlines precisely what these
theorists are saying
in a very accessible way and um
shows how these these theories that they
were just theories in universities back
in the 60s 70s 80s
but how they became mainstream how they
suddenly started um
influencing policy you know in in in in
corporations in governments in the media
how that happened is very interesting
and this book just takes you through it
in a really accessible way and i you
know that would for me
i think everyone should read that book
and they'll get they'll just get a sense
of where we're at i don't waste your
time with for co
because i wasted a lot of my life with
it
and i'm never getting that back yeah
that's fair
maybe i'll read that and talk to them on
the podcast
i think that'd be a great idea yeah i'm
interested
but they've read everything that's the
other thing they've read all this stuff
and it really winds
i love seeing james lindsay get into
scraps on twitter because these
academics hate him because he's read
more of this stuff than they have
so so they can't trick him they can't
they can't
you know and that's that's the best
thing is is he
he can see through their nonsense uh
okay
okay well that's definite definite
podcast material um
okay intersectional what does that mean
intersectional originated with a um a
legal scholar actually called kimberly
crenshaw
um and it's going back to
there was a um she wrote a paper where
she sort of coined the idea of
intersectionality and what she was
addressing was this uh
this legal issue i think it was uh
general motors
the the car company general motors and
and what happened is they
were discriminating against black women
okay and
and crenshaw was right about this there
was a point here what
what the company's defense in their case
was well look
we can't be racist because we've got all
these black men and we can't be sexist
because we've got all these white women
and crenshaw's point was yeah what about
the black women in other words you have
the intersection
of these two identities black and female
and those are the people that as she
puts it fall through the cracks and she
she was dead right
uh we're going back a long time though
these sort of things don't happen
anymore because we have employment law
and we have got um protection against
this stuff
but she was absolutely right about that
and the way that she envisioned it was
a um envisaged it was a uh an
intersection
like a crossroads two roads you know and
and what she's saying is if you if you
imagine yourself standing at the center
of this intersection
you've got traffic coming at you from
one way but also from another way as
well
as opposed to so what you're saying is
as a woman of color
you you're not just you're not just
dealing with racism which is the traffic
coming one way
you're dealing with misogyny which is
the traffic coming the other way hence
intersectional
and then that got developed into various
forms of intersection so there's other
things like if you're
if you're if you're overweight and you
get um uh fat shamed or bullied for that
if you're
if you're gay also so all sorts of so
all of these
minority identities suddenly intersect
and there is a point
to that there is a valid there is a
valid point behind it and i don't want
to be completely dismissive of it
the problem is that this analogy became
a religion
so this very this very colorful and and
helpful analogy of the intersection of a
crossroads
suddenly became this kind of a very
closed-minded religious mindset of
people who started
basically gauging where you fall on the
oppression hierarchy on the basis of how
many
intersectional points you have and that
is not actually
what crenshaw originally intended i know
that i think since she has sort of
uh engaged in this kind of stuff and
endorsed it um which is a shame but i
think
you know so so at the heart it's some it
was a good idea gone wrong
as loads of these things are it's the
same with social justice you know it's a
good idea
that when you see discrimination you
stand up and try and tackle it that's a
good idea
what's not a good idea is that you uh
start imagining that it exists in these
invisible forms absolutely everywhere
and change the world
and also silence people you don't agree
with um and
and it took this very illiberal turn so
it's the same thing with
intersectionality so that's sort of
where where
where it's come from um but again not
many people understand what the word
means and that
that can be quite funny to me that's why
with totally mcgrath
i've just written a children's book by
her which is called my first little book
of intersectional activism
and part of the joke in that is of
course no one understands what the hell
it means
and so and she's aiming this at
six-year-olds which which is funny to me
that is that is funny um i got bought a
book
what is it called i don't know my first
book on feminism or something right yeah
and it it's a real book and it's not a
joke
yeah and or the little book of feminism
or something i got that for my baby
shower and i was like dude
do you why would you bring this to me
but i still have it
yeah did you use it as an educational
tool with your children or
i i haven't started yet i mean i could
it's not
that bad but it it's not that bad but
you know it's it's on the road too bad
so um the thing is about that like
there's a whole there's so many of these
woke children's books now and some of
them are
like you say not that bad like the what
the biggest seller was this book called
good night stories for rebel girls and
all that is is
is going through sort of female icons
from history who've
achieved something i've got no problem
with that i think that's quite a good
thing uh
for girls to read about you know except
it does
it does have a chapter on coco chanel
who was a nazi collaborator but let's
leave that aside right
um it's funny they just don't mention
that bit um it's awkward isn't it
um but on the whole i don't have a
problem with that
um but the the books i do have a problem
with are the overtly ideological
political ones like anti-racist baby
anti-racist baby which is currently
selling so well in america there's
feminist baby
uh there's feminist baby that's what i
have you have feminist baby right i'm
sure i have a feminist baby
yeah so there's one called i think it's
called who are you it's
a child's guide to gender and it's aimed
at sort of five-year-olds and it's
talking about like
uh genderqueer gender fluid uh by gender
and all this stuff and i'm like
this is overt indoctrination and
i you know it's not it's not good it's
it's it's sort of
sinister um when candy uh wrote
that he's written anti-racist baby and
uh he was online asking for people's
parents to send him pictures of their
children reading the book
and there's all these photographs like
literally toddlers like babies with his
political book with black lives matter
t-shirts on and that kind of thing and
you think
these children don't know what they
think about this stuff you're you're
imposing a value system from a very
early age and i know
that you could say that's what all
religious people do but there's
something quite
this isn't a normal religion i think the
religion analogy is what is right but
it's not a normal religion it's a
it's a fundamentalist religion and
that's why it bothers me when it comes
to children and particularly
because because the ideologues have so
much power in
in the educational system particularly
in the uk i'm sure it's the same in
america and canada well actually
probably worse in canada
is that they are now successfully
bringing this into schools and
particularly in the wake of the jordan
void killing
i mean i i've had all sorts of messages
from teachers over here who are saying
oh we're now told to read white
fragility by robin d'angelo yeah
we've been told to talk to the kids
about white privilege
there was even a leaflet that was going
around the schools
saying what you need to do if a parent
claims their child isn't racist
it means you have to tackle this oh this
stuff is now mainstream it's got it and
it's
happened so quickly so so although the
titanium mcgrath children's book is a
joke
i find it's funny it's about a very
serious thing and
i i get very nervous i mean in fact in
the uk it's illegal
uh for teachers to be politically
partisan with kids under 12
but that is exactly what's happening and
it's very very dangerous
yeah i've been looking into i was
looking into daycares i have a
three-year-old
and i was trying to find a daycare that
was
a good daycare and i couldn't find one
in toronto
yeah that wasn't ideologically possessed
on their web page yeah like the one
canada's crazy isn't it like canada is
pretty bad
it's not a p it's not as bad as the
states like it's not as bad as some
areas in the states but
toronto like i couldn't find the one i
wanted i finally found one i thought was
good
and it said you know you can't dress up
as superheroes at halloween and it was
on the front
like the the front page of their website
and was like
oh no like what's the reasoning behind
that and it was all
ideological i don't even remember what
it was but it was like
well so that one's out so i think we're
gonna we're figuring out our own school
because
yeah you can't find a school now that
doesn't teach this stuff
because what's gonna happen ultimately
is i mean that
the idea of education is that you you
teach children how to be
free thinkers and you teach people to
think you know teach them
uh well you do teach them facts and
figures but you also teach them how to
think and how to analyze and how to
interpret
you don't teach them what they should be
thinking i mean that's the opposite of
education you know
and um and so therefore this stuff is
anti-educational fundamentally you're
gonna end up
with parents having to de-radicalize
their children
after school finishes which is not a a
good place to be in and
and particularly since most people are
not on board with this stuff so
yeah it's uh i mean i don't have
children so i
you know i i i don't think i don't know
what i do
i i think i'd be scared for them yeah
well i i looked at it and thought okay
we need to we looked into making a
school like you can hire a teacher and
then there are tons of people interested
in not putting their children into these
kind of
indoctrination camps so we're going to
do something like that because it
there wasn't anything that wasn't
overtly ideological it's
like terrible um and that's toronto but
oh you know what may we didn't look into
the catholic schools and i've had people
com
contact me saying i'm not religious but
my kid goes to a religious school
because
it's not as indoctrinated but even those
are
getting there so i mean i you know i
went to account i went to a conference
school it was full-on catholic
you know it was taught by nuns it was
like that and um you know
so you could say well i was heavily
indoctrinated and i suppose
uh i grew up believing in god and
believing in uh
the sacraments and all the rest of it um
but somehow
uh it as a religion and you know i'm i'm
definitely biased but as a religion
it isn't uh one that precludes other
ideas about the world and certainly
doesn't preclude discussion
or debate you know it's it's uh the
whole point is that if you have
a faith uh you're secure in it enough to
have it challenged
uh and and but that is not something
that a fundamentalist religion does
that's that's the important distinction
you know
i could have gone up to my priest and
say look uh or all of this uh walking on
the water or turning
you know turning water into wine i don't
buy this stuff can we just and he
wouldn't be like
blasphemer he wouldn't throw holy water
at me and confine me to some
oobliet he would want to talk about it
and discuss it and you know and at the
end of the day i could have said sorry i
don't believe anyone said that's fine
that's not going to happen with the
social justice ideologue what they do is
they
hence their council culture you know the
non-believers the heretics
they are destroyed their lives are
destroyed they are told they are wrong
they are told things are not up for
debate
you know it it they're like what the
catholic church was in the middle ages
when they were burning people at the
stake that's the equivalent it's not
like the modern day catholic church so
yeah if you can get into a catholic
church a catholic um
school i would i would heartily
recommend that
i think oh the catholics are fun they're
just fun they're just nice people
so uh now not in the middle ages
not in the middle ages no no burning
heretics i'm not on board with that but
but uh
you know the catholics i've known have
been fun
yeah i've heard that they're getting
infiltrated as well though well that's
the other thing i didn't realize this
until um
i spoke to a an american uh baptist
preacher
who told me about how even the baptist
and the baptist churches are quite
right-wing they're quite conservative
and evangelical he said
even they are being infected by the woke
virus unbelievably so even they are now
talking about
intersectionality and white privilege
and and even white privilege in the
bible and
uh i didn't even know how that works or
where you where you would start
with that um uh so yeah you've had
the activist sean king talking about how
we need to take down statues of white
jesus and white mary and
you know in other words desecrate
churches if they don't fulfill an
ideological
agenda that he approves of so yeah this
stuff is going to find its way
i i was surprised though to hear about
it going into religion and i mean the
whole point about the catholic church is
that it's so rooted in tradition
and so the id and sure it cut it does
develop you know he had the second
vatican council in the 1960s which
which made a lot of um progressive uh
changes
um but the idea that it would that the
catholic church can fundamentally change
in terms of its fundamental
uh precepts i don't know how that's
going to work you know
i mean the catholic church gets itself
to all sorts of problems because
they have a thing called the doctrine of
papal infallibility which means a pope
can never have said anything wrong
at any point in history right popes can
never be wrong
um so whenever they change things they
have to find a clever way to sort of say
oh that pope
back then he just meant something
different and they do this kind of
really sort of smart interpretative
sleight of hand you know to get around
the problem um
but actually that the fact that the
church stays the same and the fact that
the fundamental core beliefs stay the
same
is just part of it well i don't think
those beliefs are compatible
with social justice ideology i don't see
how that can possibly
how that could possibly work um so let's
see what happens
oh yeah i give it like two years do you
think do you think it'll be a female
pope
oh no i don't know if it'll get up there
but at least for schools and like
way further down i don't see how they're
gonna get out of it
well a friend of mine actually now
you've said it it's occurred to me a
friend of mine's starting a new job
at a catholic school in september and
they've already started sending out the
woke literature already and he's had all
this stuff he's even had to
sit in on a meeting about how they need
to address the privilege of the pupils
now bear in mind this is a
private school uh it's a school for rich
kids basically
um and they're talking about their me
and it's a boys school as well they're
talking about their male privilege
their straight privilege because most of
them will be straight they're talking
about their white privilege because most
of them are white and i'm thinking
oh minute this is a school that charges
extortionate amounts money for them to
get in no one's talking about class
privilege
no one's talking about no that school is
not discriminated against you if you're
black but it will discriminate against
you if you've got no money
right so you know if you're going to
reduce everything to privilege if you
really really want to reduce it
the main source of privilege is money
right that's it it's about cash it's
about who you know
it's about nepotism it's it's all the
advantages that come with being upper
middle class that's what that's where it
all comes from
you know it's not to do with race gender
and sexuality and no one is saying that
you can't face barriers as a result of
those things that is possible
and it does happen certainly it does
happen um
but on the whole if you're if you're
going to a posh school
in london which is charging your parents
35 grand a year or whatever
and they're they're helping you to get
cozy internships at magazines and
and at the guardian or whatever then
you're probably going to be okay
you know you're not you're not in any
way
in the same league as someone who's
grown up on a council estate with
absolutely no money that's not the same
thing so it bulks a little i get a bit
i bristle a little of these private posh
schools
putting out all these uh these um
intersectional messages all these openly
and overtly supporting the black lives
matter movement
apparently not realizing that the black
lives matter movement is a fundamentally
anti-capitalist movement and the first
institutions to be demolished would be
those ones so they're in other words
they're supporting a movement that wants
to see them destroyed
it's really weird to me um yeah well
they're hoping that
they won't be destroyed if they show
support oh is that how it works because
i saw that
i saw that riot in portland the other
night where that guy's shot was burnt
down he had a big black lives matter
sign above it but yeah
it seemed to stop it it doesn't work
like that does it uh no it doesn't
actually work like that i think that's i
think the movement is so terrifying that
people who don't want to speak out
because you might lose your friends and
your job
they just like try try and blend in but
that's not how it works
well it's like that it's like that
winston churchill quote about how you
know
appeasement is that thing about feeding
the crocodile in the hope that they'll
eat you last
that's exactly what it is you're you're
supporting a movement that does not want
you
does not want you in existence when it
comes to the private schools you know
um yeah so yeah it's uh
that to me is is is extremely extremely
troubling and i want to be able to have
conversations with
headmasters about this and ahead
mysticism and people in charge do they
realize what it is they're supporting
you know they fall them for this
rhetoric the phrase black lives matter
which is a very clever phrase because
who's going to disagree with that you
know
if you if you disagree with the movement
it sounds like you're saying black lives
don't matter but we all think that black
lives matter that argument was won
decades ago there's nobody doesn't think
that black lives matter but some of us
don't believe
that we should abolish the capitalist
system in its entirety
that's not to say there are flaws in the
capitalists but we but that's not about
abolishing it we don't believe uh that
we should dismantle the nuclear family
and cisgender privilege which is exactly
what they say on the black lives matter
website that
their goal is so all of this other stuff
is is piled into this
uh this movement it isn't just if it was
just as simple as people protesting
against instances of police brutality
and instances of racism i would be
totally on board with that because both
of those things do happen
and when they do happen they should be
opposed um
but this is a group that believes in
this kind of systemic
uh police brutality and systemic racism
even when the data
says that's not the case so they they
take individual horrific
evil acts and they extrapolate that and
decide that it therefore applies to
absolutely everything and and that's not
uh it's not a very sensible way to
proceed
yeah i've been so i've been living in
belgrade
and it's been interesting traveling
around because
that isn't here at all oh really like
that oh yeah it's not here
at all it's the complete opposite
somewhere like here or
or russia or at least in moscow it's
just a
joke oh really no no no i know it's a
joke
just like ha weak north americans
well yeah but it's spreading i mean at
first it started with the
english-speaking countries you know and
australia's got it quite bad now
um and then it's apparently it's been
creeping into spain i only know this
because
there's just been a spanish translation
of titania's first book and
and there were and there were lots of i
don't know whether the translation is
any good because i can't read spanish so
who knows what they've done with it
um but apparently i i'm now getting some
messages from spanish people saying yeah
this is happening now and
i got um but i also got this message the
other day from
an iranian guy i think he's a journalist
or something he was saying that
it'd be really interesting to translate
this into persian because
then the people of iran might see the
corruption of the western left
which that struck me as really
interesting um so you know these ideas
aren't necessarily migrating
abroad and uh and they're particularly
not
working in um in places of poverty or
dire poverty because you know
you can't go to a a destitute town uh
in in sub-saharan africa and and and
talk to them about their intersectional
privilege
i don't think that's going to work is it
they're like no where's my next bowl of
rice you know where
like i'm not i don't care about your
your first world grievances they
they're more interested in in well dare
i say trying to survive
trying to survive which you know which
matters more
yeah well even when coronavirus first
picked up everybody got quiet for a
while
he's like wow did did this just end it
and then
the george floyd thing hit and well i i
did you well the reason is i kept doing
titania in the early days of the
lockdown
people were like yeah they were even her
fans were saying
what are you doing mate this is it's
over now no one takes this stuff
seriously anymore no one's gonna care
and i wrote an article at the time which
was titled um
why coronavirus won't kill the culture
wars
and i had a lot of people saying you
don't know what you talked about people
have now tasted hardship they're not
going to care
about whether you know whether shoes are
racist or
whatever you want to come up with
they're not going to care about these
stupid things about
you know non-binary representation in
novels and so like
and then but i i i had an inkling that
actually
this was going to get worse i could see
the the social justice movement already
weaponizing the virus
you know when it became because it
started with all that discussion about
whether
we call it the chinese virus or not and
then it became about
all of that and i i could just see and
then i saw an article on cnn about
how trump's coronavirus task force was
too white and male
and i thought they're not going to let
this go you know they're not you want
them aren't they the people you want to
get coronavirus
right exactly so why are you why are you
first i think
this idea that and then there was a an
academic at oxford university who
because you know oxford were trying to
find the vaccine they were sort of um
it was sarah gilbert and her team were
at the sort of forefront of the global
search for the vaccine
and uh this other academic i think she
was i think it was gender studies
or something useless like that and she
said um i don't want
the oxford team to find the vaccine
because if it does it will be like a
victory for english colonialism all over
again thank god
and you just thought okay okay so
they're going to politicize this to the
end it's never going away like
and that's that was the thing my my one
hope was that what would happen is
you know faced with the virus and the
lockdown people would stop capitulating
they would just say you know what if
you're going to come at me and talk to
me about microaggressions or tell me i
need to have unconscious bias
training whatever i'm going to say no
i'm not doing that
you know i'm not interested in that um
but unfortunately it was this
concatenation of circumstances it wasn't
just the lockdown
it was george floyd it was blm and and
and it was and
and of course all of that exploded now
i'm not suggesting i'm a psychologist
and i understand this
but i imagine when you keep the public
locked away for a uh
yeah that's what i thought too you know
they get angry
and it exacerbates tensions that are
already there uh and then it exploded so
far from um killing the culture wars the
coronavirus
uh was a catalyst and accelerated them
yeah i thought it was going away i
really thought like i i
i didn't see anything on twitter when
people started to go into lockdown and
grocery stores were empty and people
were freaking out and everyone was
tense but also trying to help each other
and it just went silent
i was like wow is this what like oh now
that people are
scared and have something important to
think about maybe it's gone
and then wow yeah well i noticed this
because some i was joking as to time i
was making jokes about it through
titanic and people were getting angry
people who normally like her they were
like i'm retweeting this and i thought
you know uh i you know i thought because
she did something about how
she believes because she's a vegan so
she she believes that viruses have a
right to life
as well as anyone else's so she was
saying about that yeah she was saying
like
i welcome the coronavirus as an
immigrant yeah you know
and people got really angry with me
about that and i'm like
i'm i can't stop joking about something
just because it's serious i can't
i can't i think i think it's almost like
a kind of dereliction of duty if you're
if you're serious about satirizing
what's going on you have to find a way
to talk about the stuff that's going on
um and that doesn't mean you don't think
about it or you sort of rashly
throw something out there that might be
misjudged i mean look i can misjudge
sometimes we all can but i think you you
have to talk about it and
and yeah there's never a time i think
where we don't
there isn't a place for humor to deal
with things i don't know especially when
it's serious
yeah that's what i think uh so
have you ever had any like serious
backlash from this titania thing
yeah i mean i've had threats through
email and through twitter i've had uh
you know i've had the usual stuff on
twitter which i don't take seriously
which is just people mouthing off and
and even threats on twitter i don't take
seriously because i'm like if if you
wanted to attack me why would you tweet
me about it first you know it's it's
so i don't worry about that too much
some some of them have been a bit
beyond that and a bit sinister and in
those cases i've you know i've taken
them a bit more seriously but
um people get really really angry i
think most of the anger though
well there's two things i think a lot of
the anger comes from
social justice activists who don't like
being mocked you know no
high priest of any religion likes being
mocked and you you know if you know
anything about history you know that
anyone who has any
degree of power or or control over
people
the best way to undermine them as hannah
arendt said the best way to undermine
authorities through laughter
they cannot stand it this is why you
have president erdogan
of turkey who will lock up satirists in
fact he's sort of reintroduced this
obsolete turkish law
so that he can lock up anyone who
criticizes him and that includes
obviously journalists but it also
includes satirists he even tried to have
a german satirist extradited
for making a funny video about him and
shockingly
angela merkel even entertained that for
a while before backing down under
pressure but you know people in power
hate it they hate being mocked and i and
that's why the social justice lot cannot
stand to tania
and of course they don't find a funny
why would you that i'm you know if
someone was mocking me i wouldn't find
it funny either
uh so they don't find it funny and
therefore if you don't find something
that's comedic
satirical funny what's there for you you
just think it's it's rude you just think
it's aggressive
you just think it's a hostile attack so
they treat me
like i'm attacking them um which i
suppose in a sense i am
um but but but i'm not attacking them in
any serious way i'm attacking them
through
through satire and humor which i think
is relatively benign
um but i think the other element of the
people who hate it are the people who
just don't find it funny right so
because there's something about comedy
um when you don't find something funny a
lot of people they get angry about that
and i'm not just talking about things
that offend this oh yeah oh yeah i'm
just talking about your taste in
standard like
and i've never really got this if i go
and see a stand-up comic i can often
watch a stand-up comic and not crack a
smile and think i don't see what's funny
about this
but i can see that everyone else is
laughing and so what i don't do is think
i don't
i don't i never say the phrase that's
not funny because what i'm thinking is
well that's quite a narcissistic thing
to say because what i'm saying is
my sense of humor is the only sense of
humor that matters all of you other
people that are laughing must be wrong
how could it be otherwise because i am
the center of the universe so i think
someone who says that's not funny
it's so subjective it's a bit like
saying that's not erotic
you know how useful is that you know
because you know i might not find
certain things erotic and someone else
is into
you know whatever stuffed fish or what i
don't know but like like everyone's got
different
ideas about what's erotic and everyone's
got different ideas about what's funny
and
and um and there's room for it all like
i don't it doesn't bother me that there
are comics i mean i watch some stand-ups
and i think
i don't even see what you're getting at
here i don't find it funny and i don't
see why people are laughing and i have
these complete
i'm like it's inexplicable to me and and
i understand that that's probably how a
lot of people think about
what i do um and that's also why you get
a lot of hecklers now who
who who want to put a stop to the show
you know there's a real sense of like
people standing up and saying no
i don't like this or i'm offended by
this that's the one we get a lot
and therefore i'm gonna no one else
should be allowed to listen because i
get to decide
and again i think it's about narcissism
and entitlement you know if i don't like
a stand-up show i just won't laugh
problem solved or i just won't go and
see that comic again problem solved easy
um but if i were to stand up and shout
as a woman did to me at the edinburgh
fringe festival
and try and put a stop to the show then
basically what i'm admitting is
i don't i'm everything must change for
me
only my taste matters i think oh god i
mean yeah she got really angry with me
she
accused me of misogyny and it was and
again she was making the mistake of
taking what i was saying literally and
the idea of taking a joke literally
doesn't make any sense i'm not literally
saying what i think is a standard
i'm you know i'm as it happens i was
mocking the then prime minister theresa
may
and i think that's punching up right
theresa is a lot more powerful than i am
you know and and so it's weird to me and
i want i didn't even mean it
really like i i don't have a problem
theresa may it's just my onstage persona
had a problem with theresa may you know
that's the other thing people don't get
is that stand-up comics aren't
themselves they're a kind of
theatricalized version of themselves and
and that's why i don't get it as well
when people are angry at me for
something titania has said it's like
i'm not i'm not literally saying what i
think here i'm just i'm
i'm embodying a role to satirize the
follies and vices
of society that i think need to be held
up to ridicule
and that's not the same thing as as as
a sort of hostile mean or vicious attack
you know
and we're actually quite careful about
that because i'm not a confrontational
person i don't
i i don't go out of my way to be mean
and i and i
uh and i always think about the tweets i
put out there and i i try and make sure
that i'm not
it's difficult because even if you're
mocking the prime minister there's
always the potential
that that person could read what you've
said and get upset but
you know i think ultimately satire can't
exist unless you're mocking those in
power and that's not to say that i
don't recognize that they are human
beings with feelings but you know they
they do have more responsibilities than
the rest of us and
they're in the game so they've made the
choice you know
yeah i've note i've noticed too people
people from different cultures sometimes
have a difficulty with dry humor which
seems to be
british but like north american they use
dry humor and i noticed that
um when i met my husband because he's
russian and so his family didn't have
dry humor and i have an
extremely dry sense of humor and i'd say
things and he'd go that's not funny like
they can do that
yeah and i'd be like i'm kidding though
like it's a joke and
it's taken like four years but i think
that's very
specific very specific to western
culture as the dry sense of humor
like a lot of people a lot of cultures
don't poke fun at themselves
self-deprecating humor especially yeah
that's like that's not very common in
russia or asia from what i know um
that's a western thing
there's even differences though between
the west there's even there's a there's
a big difference between the uk and
america
on that score like i wrote a show which
toured america but it started off
touring england and it went over to
america
but the central character was a very
self-deprecating sort of
um low status figure
and so it whereas it was working really
well in the uk it didn't work in america
because
there was an expectation that they're
here the hero of the story shouldn't be
low status
and so they couldn't laugh along with
him they just sort of felt sorry for him
and it was a there was so there was a
weird disparity there and i have noticed
sometimes
with americans when i've when i'm well
when i'm being sarcastic
it will be taken literally and uh maybe
that's my own fault but that does happen
a lot and on twitter it can happen a lot
because of course
there's no tone there i get that yeah
twitter is hard
but then what you're going to do you
can't use emojis because it'll undermine
the joke like the whole this is the
thing about satire as well like
the joke only works if you're straight
faced like it's the same with standard
comics stand-up comics that laugh at
themselves on stage i never find funny
i i have to believe that they believe
what this that the character believes
what they're saying
um and this is why i love the image that
my friend made for titania you know the
face of titania
because she's so po-faced and so
straight-faced uh
and and and so therefore all of her
tweets you see this face next to the
tweet
which is sort of almost daring you to
mock her and you know really sneering at
you and that really helps the
the humor and a lot of people say to me
well you should say that it's satire you
should
you should put a a sign and stop it but
then
that undermines undermines the whole
thing yeah the whole thing yeah so
yeah yeah yeah i'm aware of those those
cultural differences in
in terms of humor as well i'm aware of
it
so didn't titania get cancelled just a
couple of weeks ago
yeah taken off twitter right well that's
happened about eight or nine times now
you know
uh and she's had two seven day bands
uh a number of one day bands she's had a
permanent
ban it was and i i had the email from
twitter saying that
she's gone now she can't come back and
that got reversed the next day
because there was some kind of outcry
about it and um
and she wrote an article about why she
you know
being in the twitter wilderness she she
said being banned from twitter for a day
she said now i know how nelson mandela
felt
that was her article and um but yeah so
a couple of weeks ago same thing
happened she was locked out of the
account and
i couldn't get in and there was no way
to get in this was the other thing so so
there was no sort of system in place and
i'd i'd sent them a couple of messages
but there was there
i just got those usual automated
responses that's what happens with
twitter you know
there's no one there's no physical human
being to talk to there's no call center
there's
it's just an automated response that's
why when you appeal
a lot of the suspensions and things like
that um
often it doesn't it doesn't work i mean
nothing nothing actually happens in the
end and
you you end up just uh losing your
account
so for some reason in the last couple of
weeks this has happened to me
and yet i don't know why but she's she's
come back and i don't know what happened
i didn't get any messages or anything
she just reappeared one day but but
what's interesting is on the same day
that she was locked out
about 10 or 11 other satire accounts
were suspended
well actually deleted banned including
my friend
lisa who she runs an account called
jarvis dupont
um who was a brilliant hilarious uh
account and um it got nuked by twitter
and there's no reason given
at all um so i don't know and i said to
lisa you know are you going to appeal it
and she said but she's been in that
she's had loads of accounts appeals
just for jokes um and maybe that's part
of that cultural difference that we were
talking about is that maybe in silicon
valley
they don't get humor maybe they don't
get the the the satire maybe they don't
get that it's not meant to be taken
literally i don't know
they're engineers well they're nerds is
that but there's also the fact that
they're all ideologues and they're all
um
you know the the people that the trust
and safety council that twitter has god
can you
i co you know if someone would say to me
come up with the most orwellian
sounding dystopian fiction name for a
council of speech monitors
i don't think i'd come up with anything
more effective than the trust and safety
council it sounds terrifying
they sound like a bunch of sith lords or
something it's terrifying and anyway
they
they whoever it is who monitors the
content of twitter they they don't like
social justice being mocked or the ideas
they don't like the left being mocked
and i couldn't help but think well
democratic national conference coming up
is it part of that the elections coming
up is it that they don't want the left
to get mocked
is that what this is about because it is
suspicious i mean you might say
these satire accounts have somehow
fallen foul of the twitter terms of
service which are
so vague by the way as to enable them to
ban people for any reason whatsoever
um but would that have happened all of
the same afternoon on the same day
i don't think so i think there was a
purge of satire and i think it was for
ideological reasons and of course
there's no way to verify that because no
one at twitter will talk to you because
it's such a closed ship it's it's it's
so
shady it's so shady and dodgy
um and i keep hearing people saying oh
it's come on sorry
it's across social medias as a whole
though i just got
demonetized for some reason i don't know
why but
my channel is demonic you've got the
wrong opinions didn't you know
like that's how this works right you i
mean
and it's just so weird and the more they
do this stuff the more they drive people
to to explore these ideas in in
different ways non-mainstream ways and
it's going to be their own undoing
ultimately the problem is all of the
major
social media sites youtube google
facebook uh
twitter are all singing from the same
hymn sheet they've all got the identical
world
view and they all believe that
censorship is a good thing one of the
the most dangerous aspects of the social
justice ideologies
is is as i say this belief which is
derived from this post-modern
emphasis on language uh that actually
certain kind of language is hateful
and violence they call speech they say
speech is violence don't they and they
talk about
safe spaces and the the rhetoric of
safety
which implies that these these somehow
these syllables are causing you actual
harm and this is not
true it's simply not true and so
therefore what this does is justify
not only retaliative violence in the
form of antifa
or groups like that who say that well
this trump voter
has said some mean words and therefore i
can hit them that justifies my
because it's self-defense against their
violent words so yeah that's that's what
it does on the one hand
on the other hand it provides a kind of
justification
for censorship and that's ultimately
what all authoritarians do
and the fact that people can't see the
authoritarian uh
elements that underpin this movement
baffles me i
it's so clearly the case anything that
believes that there has to be this kind
of
approved way of thinking that comes from
on high
uh and that any deviation from that is a
form of heresy that needs to be
controlled
and that people need to be censored and
they even lose their jobs and livelihood
if they stray from the approved ideas
how is that anything other than
authoritarian and fine they're not
locking up people in gulags
yet but it's the same
sentiment that lies underneath and and
and so i do not
you know when i use the word liberal i
use in the traditional british sense of
the word not in america it just means
left-wing or democrat which isn't
the way we use it actually liberal
values are a really good thing because
what liberal values means is
everyone gets to say what they want
write what they want think what they
want and have the discussion in open
and we get to disagree as long as you're
not harming the rights of another human
being
that's the liberal system and that's the
best system and it's also the best
system for tackling things like
racism sexism homophobia the the worst
way to tackle those things
is the divisive ideology of social
justice that just simply divides
people up into their own little corners
and um and
and and senses and and uh attacks people
if they want to raise issues and this
and this is particularly important with
things like the trans issue
where we haven't had a public discussion
about this so you know you can shout
trans women or women all you like on
twitter but the vast majority of people
don't understand what you mean
and don't believe that it's right and
don't believe that they should be using
all these new pronouns and things like
that
because the discussion has not been
allowed we haven't had that discussion
we had it with gay rights
we had we had decades of protest and
debate and discussion about gay marriage
that argument was won and it wasn't one
through force no one put anyone in
prison for using the wrong words about
gay people or having the wrong ideas
about gay people
um um there was a bit of bullying going
on like i don't approve of this i think
if someone
disapproves or disagrees with gay
marriage that's their opinion they
should have the right to have that
opinion
and a lot of people just dismiss them as
bigots and that's not fair
um but on the whole uh we reached a kind
of equality through
through through liberal ideas discussion
that you know debate and like i say
protest as well i'm all for protest it's
a mark of a civilized society
we haven't had that discussion we had
that discussion with slavery
and you know that was you know a long
time ago decades
of people um you know the clapham sect
and and and william will before some
people like this who are pushing for
these
these radical changes and they were and
it didn't happen easily
it happened with this with with rigorous
debate and rigorous protest and it
happened
and now you won't find a single person
who agrees that slavery is a good thing
in spite of what
certain activists will tell you um and
we had it with gay rights we didn't have
it with the trans issue just one day
about five years ago
these powerful people said no from now
on you have to agree
that the the biological sex is a myth
and that there are no you know that that
um
it is possible to to uh to change your
your biology which by the way most trans
people don't believe
it's it's just the minority of extreme
activists
and because we haven't you know in the
uk we've had people arrested
for one woman was arrested for uh
misgendering someone on twitter and she
was arrested in front of a child
and put in a cell and so this kind of
stuff is going on
uh we've had people lose their jobs oh
we had it the other day there's a new
york uh
literary agency called the tobias
literary agency fired
a member of their staff because she had
a view on on the use of pronouns
and new pronouns and pronouns such as
they them which she considered to be an
anti-feminist thing
uh she wasn't rude about it she wasn't
aggressive or hostile she just expressed
an opinion on her private twitter
account
and they fired her um and that's
so this has happened all of a sudden
without the discussion that is
fundamentally illiberal and i and so i
i hope people understand and begin to
understand that social justice ideology
is an illiberal movement it's an
authoritarian movement
it's it's regressive it's taking us back
it's undermining
uh everything that was fought for in the
civil rights where where martin luther
king
advanced this idea of colour blindness
which is a really beautiful idea
which doesn't mean that you don't notice
race it just means that you don't treat
people differently because of race and
that is a really beautiful ideal
and the social justice movement don't
believe in that in fact some people have
even started to call might looking a
self-hating racist
they believe that actually what this is
is we should be obsessing about race
and and re-racializing society and and
and and
reintroducing all of this stuff that we
tried to get rid of
i find it desperately sad actually i
mean i know i joke about it
because i think that's quite an
effective way to tackle it but also
because i just
that's my instinct but actually i do
find it really depressing and i think i
think when you see society
back peddling to such an extent in the
name of progress
and you see people being illiberal in
the name of liberalism
then i think you have to speak out yeah
i i guess one would argue that some of
the people that let's say this trans
movement that just got
kind of like you said there's no
conversation around it yeah i guess one
might argue that
slavery and gay marriage shouldn't have
had to go through the war that they went
through in order to be legalized and
that's
probably the argument they used for for
the pronouns and everything it's like
well we don't
that fight was unfair so yes this is
just how it is now
doesn't that just tell you all you need
to know about the way in which a lot of
the social justice ideologues deny
reality
you can't progress doesn't just happen
because it should happen
you know uh i mean yes uh slavery was
never right
i don't care even if even if everyone
thought it was right at the time which
a lot of people did well if you ask the
slaves they might have a different view
on that
you know i think it was always a great
evil
um and uh
you know it was an evil that a lot of
people who should have known better were
complicit in and by the same token
a lot of people didn't know better and
and were taught from an early age that
it was a positive thing even a moral
thing and and so there
it's very difficult to judge those
people by the standards of of today
um but then you did have people like i
say like the clapham sect who stood up
and
and and said no this is not only is it
morally wrong it's anti-christian it's
against you know it's it's
it's against the the ideas of jesus
christ so
you know uh yes absolutely slavery
should never have happened
we live in the real world where it did
happen and it required
work hard work to overturn it so
simply wishing away something that is
bad
isn't isn't right so when it comes to
the trans issue
the liberal perspective solves
everything as in the liberal perspective
says
anyone has the right to identify however
they want call themselves whatever they
want
do whatever they want to their bodies
have whatever surgery they feel they
need
anything like that but they do not have
the right to compel others
to use language that they may not want
to use to go to
you know i haven't got the right to go
to a christian a christian person and
say
you don't agree with gay marriage but
you must call my partner my husband
and if you don't i'm gonna have you
locked up no i've got no right to do
that
i've got a right to express my view on
that and say to this person look
i would rather you call this person my
husband but but you know
i can do that but the liberal
perspective is that everyone has the
right to to speak how they want to speak
and say what they want to say and that
includes about themselves and about
others
um and it solves everything if that's
that's the solution now the the trans
uh activist i know you talk about the
extreme trans activists here because
most trans people are not on board with
this stuff
most trans people just they don't they
don't like the fact that their
their rights are being tarnished or the
the the the way people perceive them is
being tarnished by
by the worst excesses of a a very
bullying
vicious minority um but
their view is they want to impose these
ideas i mean i don't need to tell you
this you know what what your father went
through with with uh
bill c-16 is it it's the same thing it's
like it isn't the point
that if if someone he knew wouldn't have
would have asked him to use pro
their pronouns he wouldn't have done so
it was the idea that the government was
legislating and saying we are going to
compel you to do so
and that's dead wrong i mean that is
authoritarianism and and
and it doesn't matter what the principle
is it didn't need to be about trans
issues he was right to take a stand
against it yeah
and we all have to do that we all have
to say you know
when it comes to this stuff about white
privilege when it comes to stuff about
all of this this this stuff that's being
pushed through now it's like
no i'm not going to be forced to say
something i know not to be
true that's that's the thing and and and
with the trans ideology
you know george takai tweets about how
uh
biological sex is a myth and i think i'm
not gonna be forced to say that that's
right
because because it's not right uh and as
blair white said you know
blair white's a trans person in america
she said um if there's no such thing as
biological sex there's no such thing as
being trans
you know so the the the truth does
matter actually um and you have to deal
with the world as it is not as you would
wish it to be and if you
and if you see something wrong uh
you should you should try and change it
and i think when it comes to trans
rights
that's the other thing is the people who
are imposing these ideas
are often wrong okay so it's not
good or moral to uh to create a hundred
new different pronouns and expect people
to to learn them
you know that's that's actually a debate
they should lose and actually in the
marketplace of ideas
they would lose that debate um but they
are right to say that no one should be
discriminated against simply because
they are trans
that's that's where they're they're
right no one should be hurt or attacked
because they are trans um so yeah i'm on
board with equal rights for everyone
i'm not on board with the imposition of
language the aggressive imposition of
language that we're seeing now even from
online dictionaries who are changing
definitions
so merriam-webster dictionary added they
as a singular plural
the other year even though it hasn't
caught on with the general public most
of the vast majority people don't use it
as a singular plural
and even find it very confusing to do so
it jars when they attempt to do so
um and yet i mean the dictionary's
traditional role is to record common
usage it is not
to try and socially engineer us to try
and
change the way people speak for
ideological reasons it's not
you know merriam-webster have also
changed uh or
are intending to change the definition
of racism so it no longer means
hatred or prejudice against someone due
to their skin color or race
but it means prejudice plus power which
is the critical race theory idea of what
racism means now once they've implied no
you'll notice that
virtually no one thinks that no one
outsides of the outside of critical race
theorists and
writers for the guardian and writers for
the new statesmen of this niche
group of ideologues outside of that most
people don't know what you're talking if
you say
racism is an equation they're like what
are you talking about racism is just
hating people because they're race
so when the dictionary takes that step
and says no everyone's wrong
we've got our own little cohort in these
offices and we're going to impose this
new definition
uh and you can't argue about it because
it's in the dictionary right
that's social engineering and that's not
this and that's again
uh this idea of people seizing control
of language and trying to
trying to say we are going to control
the way you speak
for god's sake have these people not
read george orwell it's become a cliche
to talk about george
probably haven't but yeah but they
should
not that they'd understand it but like
it's i don't care if it's a cliche
all of this was anticipated and not just
in 1984
but if you read orwell's essays which i
think everyone should read
he has many essays about this very issue
about the way in which language language
is you know in order to control thought
people control language or they make
that attempt
um and i'm you know and again it
comes back to authoritarianism and you
know i'm just i'm not going to go with
that fight basically that's my
that's my feeling about it yeah good
well
thank you for joining me oh that was
quick
that was interesting yeah that's it
these are these are hours out an hour
long
wow amazing i felt like it's not like 10
minutes
no that was fun that year you've read a
lot
that was very interesting yeah well i
don't have many friends so i have a lot
of time
to sit at home and just read
read portray to tanya yeah exactly
exactly well thanks for having me yeah
that was a lot of fun um where can
people find you other than
on twitter at titania mcgrath well yeah
and also because she'll probably get
banned eventually so i i wouldn't just
put that out i
you can find me on twitter at andrew
doyle underscore com
i've also got a website which is a
android oil dot co
dot uk um and yeah and my book
the new tiny book is out in a couple of
weeks and it's called my first little
book of intersectional activism so
why not why not check that out yeah yeah
definitely i'm going to
thank you very much for coming thanks a
lot makayla
if you enjoyed this episode please rate
it leave a review
and next week i have jocko willink
so stay tuned for that have a good week
you